your mother and sister are here with you
is that right that is right they here at
the show they are there backstage they
just flew in we had a little bit of a
situation because my mom tried Airbnb
for the first time and she got to her
Airbnb place and she found out that the
guy that is renting to her is actually
gonna sleep on the couch
he's not leaving a part not leaving he's
sleeping on the couch and said she could
take his room and and um he also forgot
that she was coming today so like his
stuff was all over the bed and um and
it's like oh she's not gonna stay in
that apartment with a strange man
he is cuz she thinks that maybe he'd be
cool cuz he drives a Harley and does
p90x he also asked her if she wanted to
go bungee jumping
so she know like I think it could be fun
well knesset and I was like you're gonna
get murdered yeah I'm chopped up in the
time well you're the one shouting kill
kill kill let me ask you a question why
can't your mom stay and your sister stay
with you well she can't will my sister
sing with me cuz I don't have the enough
I don't have a big enough bed for the
both of them and I don't want to put her
on the couch or anything so I thought
she would have her own little like yeah
you know place so maybe she could stay
with you cuz you probably haven't heard
Oh me she could stay with me yeah yeah
she if only if she brings the Harley guy
I think it's gonna be interesting it's
his name yeah his name's Aaron oh cool
yeah Wow
so it's a real story this is really
going down mom is staying with a strange
man happening Wow suitcases in his
bedroom and we're all we're like
planning on how to like just get her out
out of there
I don't know it's Hollywood baby I don't
you